well anybody else who has directv knows
also that when you click on it it says
hey call this phone number so that you
can order this so we put it under first
of all how do you know that
[Applause]
beth and i went away on vacation for the
weekend my parents his grandparents came
to stay with him the next month we
looked at our directv bill and there was
200 worth of porn on
he blamed his grandparents my mom and
dad when i asked him about it he was
like well they do like each other a lot
when i was jacob's age at the time of
this story
i had discovered 976 numbers
those who don't know what 976 phone
numbers were those were numbers that you
called and there was a recording of a
woman on the phone for probably two
minutes
i know that's all i was
around they cost a certain amount of
money
every time you call
i called
that number a couple times and my dad
walks up to me like i walked to him with
the bill
with all the phone numbers
now you know what i didn't know at that
age
that there were things called itemized
bills
that when you order something
it shows the [ __ ] up on a piece of paper
that is sent to your home
my text shows me this
not only was i embarrassed
that he knew
but i was embarrassed that i had called
it
27 times in a row
so he puts it down
and he goes
do you know anything about this
[Music]
it's a
it's a sex line
and i go
oh like
like educational
he goes
are you telling me
somebody broke into the house
didn't steal anything
made 27 phone calls in a row
and left
and i was like that does sound pretty
crazy to me too
anyways this wasn't you i'm like nah i
just took it to my grave
because i didn't know at the time that
anybody would ever find out
what it was
you know who knows what an itemized bill
is
my 85 year old father 100
sure he would know that anal party three
would show up
on my [ __ ] bill
i rest my case
okay okay
so here's
i know that ordering porn on television
is such an old person thing to do
like you already have a joke about me
getting caught with my like watching it
online so why am i then
switching it up hold on i gotta start
writing down my answers
answer that like why would i change up
if you've already got a joke about me
watching it online like why am i then
going to like
find it on the television do you want to
answer that right now anyway
you said that once i rebuttal you were
going to remote button so this is your
time
look for those of you who have directv
you know you know once you flip past
500s you're getting into the danger zone
he's a curious kid and what do you he
thinks the channel stopped at five eight
seven no he kept going he saw porn he
was like yo i'll [ __ ] take a look at
that
you know what i'm saying and then you
you just thought whatever you thought
what i thought nobody's ever going to
see it it'll just show up in in the
number
you know what i mean well anybody else
who knows who has directv knows also
that when you click on it it says hey
call this phone number so that you can
order this so we put it on first of all
how do you know that
[Applause]
so then here's my thing also with
grandpa knowing that it will show up and
you know him knowing that he you like to
[ __ ] with people and he likes to [ __ ]
with people
is there any way that this was a plot
twist and that he bought it didn't watch
it but just wanted you to think that
somebody in the house
did
we might i might you and i might
actually need to share a joint together
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
here's the thing i
have never thought of that
that's why i rest my case on why i think
i'm smarter than you yeah no but i
i don't think that
listen man just the way he's answered me
he's answered me like
the tone in his voice is like are you
seriously asking me this question
yo did you
so jacob did a reaction video to
watching my the joke about him ordering
the porn right
then my dad did a reaction video to
jacob's reaction
and for 12 minutes straight called you a
[ __ ] liar yeah
yeah
i'm still old i'll die on that hill i
know i didn't do it
okay now that you've heard
our
arguments so how many people think he
did
[Applause]
how many people think that my my parents
[Applause]
how is he poor
he said one thing
i [ __ ] laid out dude i should be a
lawyer that was so good
2014 i'm living liquor just to make it
to another 24.
foreign
[Music]
forty-five